>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Andrew Robb: Hi, I'm Andrew Robb.
I'm section head for special format
conservation here at the library
and I'm filling in for Archie
Felmer Useman [assumed spelling]
who couldn't be here this
afternoon; he sends his regrets.
But let me introduce our
speaker for the 79th lecture
in our topics in preservation
series.
Paul Messier is our speaker and
his innovations in the field
of conservation are noteworthy: the
formation of a reference collection
of photographic papers and related
project regarding the development
of the texture scope, topics
that Paul discussed here in 2010
and are available on
our series of webcasts
on the preservation website.
Along with these accomplishments,
for many years Paul was principle
of the successful photograph
conservation practice Paul Messier
LLC specializing in the treatment
and characterization of 19th
and 20th century photography
especially the characterization
of the photographs of
Louis Hein and Menrey.
I'd also say that along
with his work
in that practice he's trained
a number of people many
of whom are here and on the webcast
and I know they're all appreciative
of his efforts in that regard too.
Well, this practice is
still strong and on-going.
In 2015, Paul was appointed
head of the Lens Media Lab,
a start up to this part of the
Institute for the preservation
of cultural heritage
at Yale University.
His talk today, Expressive
Dimensions
Of Photographic Papers is
another chapter of Paul's work
to better understand the
materials used by photographers
so that we can better interpret
them and care for them.
Paul Messier.
[ Audience Clapping ]
>> Paul Messier: Thanks Andrew and
thanks to everybody for showing up.
It's really nice to see
somebody familiar faces,
it's great, great to be here.
So let's get started, okay.
Without any fooling around,
this is one of my favorite
things in the world.
This is a gaverit sample book
of photographic papers
from the mid-1930s.
I'm just going to play around these
a little bit and you get the sense
of why this is just so cool.
You know, and when you look at this,
is just like unnecessary greatness.
I mean how many surfaces
is that 38, 36.
No, well I can't count right now,
somebody can do 4 times 9 minus 2.
>> Thirty seven.
>> Paul Messier: Thirty seven,
no, it is not an odd number.
[ Laughter and background
discussion ]
>> Thirty four.
>> Paul Messier: Thirty
four, okay, class dismissed,
let's go, let's, I'm done.
Yeah, okay, that is
very good Andrew.
So, yeah, I mean why does any
company need so many surfaces
of black and white paper?
What's going on here?
And I think, you know, we,
the black and white medium
that we have received
in the 21st century,
what's left of it is this kind of
dim echo of this amazing diversity
that was, that existed for much
of the century and you know,
this is sort of a microcosm
of what was available.
This is one company's paper
selection for one year,
if you multiply this by
five or eight, you know,
international companies, big
corporations like Kodak and Ilford
and Agfa and many other smaller
companies, you get a sense
of how rich the medium
of black-and-white silver
gelatin whatever you want
to call photography is, and it
became important to me to try
to catalog, to try to
understand this diversity and try
to understand what was going
on, what was promoting this,
why did they need so many
surfaces, what did that represent?
And one of the ways that I
settled on in terms of trying
to get a handle on all of this
is just really looking closely
at a package of paper
and on the package
of paper is pretty much all you
really need to know about one aspect
of characterization,
one aspect of how
to characterize a photographic
paper and let's see
if I can get this to
work yeah, okay.
So what we're looking at here
is basically four dimensions
that the manufacturers were
trying to convey to photographers
and that photographers
were fluent in at the time.
So here are the four dimensions.
What's the base color?
What color is the base?
In this instance it's ivory white.
What's the texture
and what's the gloss?
Here we have one word per color
which refers to both texture
and gloss, if you know
per color is a fabric,
it's a tightly woven
I think cotton fabric
with the satiny lustery finish
so both a texture and a gloss.
And then what's the base, what's
the support, how fit is it really?
I mean that's basically all that is.
How much of an assertive physical
presence does the material have
and so this is, you know, this
is a kind of carton, it is,
you know, it's a thicker support.
So here we have the four dimensions
that as I say there was a real
fluency in these four dimensions
that I think, you know, we don't
actually perceive so much anymore
in terms of contemporary
black and white papers.
I did a project in 2012 at
the Museum of Modern Art.
My research was really
focused on well can I make,
can make those four dimensions
relevant in a contemporary context
where they are useful for anything
when it comes to classification,
characterization of
photographic materials.
And so, you know, this is one
of the prints that I was looking
at was this Helmar Lerski
in the MOMA collection.
And so here are the four dimensions
and then the first three are
actually really pretty easy
to measure.
Thickness, well, you just
get a micrometer, gloss,
you get a gloss meter and this
is all pretty conventional stuff.
Color spectrophotometer
and what I'm measuring
or what I'm representing here
is just how yellow it is,
how far along on this B axis
in the LAP color space is it.
So it's 5.7 okay, great.
Texture was a problem
and we convened a group
of signal processing engineers
and we asked them to look
at texture images to try
to back out some numbers
to help us classify paper texture.
So we settled on a method
that kind of centered
on a two-dimensional
raking light image
of the surface of a
photographic paper.
Represented here is about six
and half millimetre square
and so we took images like this
and we had four different signal
processing teams and they came
up with four different algorithms
for classifying these
kinds of images.
One of them does what I
would do if I knew anything
about signal processing, I mean the
difference is, mine is in my head
and there's actually works.
It's based on using the brightness
of the pixels as a proxy for height.
So the brighter the pixel
the higher the surface,
the darker the pixel the lower
the surface and when you do
that you can conceive of an
image, a two-dimensional image
in a really a three-dimensional way.
And this is all false and rendered
but you see what's going on here.
So you can take that
pseudo-topography let's call it
and then you can start
breaking it down and backing
out some numbers and, you know,
now we have these fractals.
We basically cast the
net over our surface
and we have different
mesh dimensions.
We can cast a really wide
net or really narrow net
and that becomes a
classification scheme,
so we can back out some numbers now.
So this is amazing, just
wait for it texture, okay?
Yes, I mean 4.9 scale one
pseudo-area scale fractal analysis,
okay, I know what a
millimeter is, you know,
and I kind of can see
what a gloss unit is,
although that's pretty abstract but
I'm not, you know, so these numbers,
well, they're are important.
They're almost, they're
non-nutritive,
it doesn't convey the information
that I really needed to convey.
So I started to think about how
we can make put those numbers
into context and as some
you may know I've, you know,
I've been obsessively collecting
photographic papers for a long time.
And I have like around
6000 and I was so glad
to see Laurene [assumed
spelling] here
because Laurene Vargo [assumed
spelling] was in my studio
at the start of this
collecting and she did a lot
of the initial cataloging
on this collection.
And this collection is
come with me to Yale
and it's really the
foundation of the work at least
in the initial phases
of the Lens Media Lab.
So let's just call this the genome
and so let's put those numbers
into context of the genome.
How can we, you know, what do we
learn when we compare the numbers
for a particular print to, you know,
6000 or so photographic papers,
that gives us the context
that we need.
And so we can take this or
here's an example of that.
This is like a really easy
example to understand I think.
There's a few thousand
thickness measurements here
from the collection and
you can see, you know,
it's intrinsically
valuable information.
I mean you can see, you
know, there's breakout
of single weight papers as single
weight was actually thinner before
1930 and then it got a
little thicker after 1930.
Double weight, you know, you can
see the range of double weight,
you can see after 1980, you
know, when the industry is sort
of beginning to collapse
and consolidate.
You see a collapsing consolidation
of single and double weight
into this sort of mushy
medium way kind of thing.
Okay, that's interesting in and of
itself but if you put the Lerski
in here which measures
at one, you know,
about 0.17 or so millimeters thick.
You can see it's right in the
heart of single weight papers
but you can also kind of
intuitively see that, you know,
there is about fifteen
percent papers that are thinner
and about eighty five percent
papers that are thicker.
And so using that, you know, as a
strategy we can put these numbers
into a better context, we
can replace all of that
with just really kind
of simple visualizations
and that's just based
on a percentile.
So for the Lerski, you know,
like I said about fifteen percent
of papers are thinner so
that's the fifteen percent
about eighty five are thicker.
Gloss it's a pretty matte paper, is
a lot of papers that are glossier.
Color is right in the middle between
kind of neutral like bluish white
and warm white with stripes
it splits the difference
in texture it's got
a lot of texture.
Alright, well, that's great.
So, you know, how can we
really use this information?
How can we better use
this information?
I'm all about, you know, trying to,
you know; visualize these things
into as intuitively as possible.
And So this is a step
in the direction.
If you've got any great ideas
about how to visualize this data
and make it more accessible
I would love to here it.
So I arrange those four axes
like this and I put kind
of the more expressive
dimensions, the rougher papers,
the thicker papers, the more matte
papers, the more warm papers.
I've oriented them to the
outside of this kind of
but going to become this glyph.
Here's the Lerski data
plotted and I want to clean it
up a little bit and that.
So that is my, well, it's a glyph;
it's a thumbprint that stands
in for the material characteristics
of this photographic paper.
And so it gives me a really
quick visual reference of what,
not what this image is but
what this material is so, okay.
So how do you use that?
How can that be useful to us?
I think we're going to go
back to my favorite thing
and we're going to
look at two papers.
This is called Large X [assumed
spelling]; I think that's right
and this is called Doug Divalux
Velore [assumed spelling].
And so Large X on the left and
Divalux Velore on the right
and you can see Doug Divalux is
plotted in the sort of glyph right
at the edges of the universe
of expressive possibilities.
It's got more texture, it's
thicker, it's more matte,
it's warmer than any of the papers,
most of the papers by far most
of the papers in the
collection that I've measured.
And this was a deluxe paper,
this was a paper designed
for highly expressive
self-realized photographic artists,
it was incredibly expensive, it was
the most and they were proud of it.
It's the most expensive
photographic paper of the time.
They called it the most
beautiful photographic paper, no;
they called it the most
beautiful paper ever manufactured.
Didn't call it the most
beautiful photographic paper;
the most beautiful
paper ever manufactured.
It was sold in very
few contrast grades,
you had to know what you're doing,
you had to have a good
negative to print with this.
On the other hand large X [assumed
spelling] which occupies the sort
of inside of this universe of
possibilities, this is, you know,
the faster they come to
better you'll like it.
What they're talking about is
photofinishing, this is a paper made
for commercial photo finishers.
It's the ideal rapid photofinishing
paper, this was sold, yes,
you could buy sheets but more
commonly you would buy roles
of this stuff.
It was about five times
less expensive than Divalux
and so what you have here is
this the two ends of the spectrum
for that particular
year of Divalux paper...
of gaveric papers, you know.
This for one segment of the market
and for one very specific sort
of expressive intent and
this on the opposite.
And you know, I like to think
about numbers I guess but I also
like to think about words
and semantic meaning.
And so here are the two paper
side-by-side, two advertisements
from the period and I'm
just overlay some words
and in these words I think convey
the meaning of the, you know,
the inside of that
glyph, the small one is
when that glyph is really small and
tight and centered in the focus.
You're talking about an object that
speaks objectively, it's a document,
it's real and you can compare
like this list of words, you know,
I like some of these things,
it's cerebral, you know,
to and I made all this
up by the way.
This is not like, you know, any
sort of orthodoxy here, I mean,
you can make up your own.
So for objective purposes, to convey
information versus subjective,
to convey a high level
of discernment,
this is for straight
photography, this is more skewed,
this is functionalist,
this indulgent,
this is utilitarian, this is art.
You know, you can kind of
actually when you think
about expressive dimensions
of photographic paper,
you can actually think
about expressive dimensions
of like a chair, you know.
I think, you know, I could go to
work for IKEA now with this and put
like this into their catalog like,
where do you fall on the expressive
versus functional dimension,
you know, for this chair
or this picture whatever.
This is very functional,
utilitarian, it's straight,
it's not skewed, it's
utilitarian, it's not art;
I don't know about cerebral, anyway.
So you get the point, right?
I just happened to be
running around yesterday
and came upon Kathy
Mitty's project here
and she's got this great project and
she's working with Adrian Lundgren
on it to look at technical manuals
and catalog photographs, you know.
Actual photographs to get
put into these manuals
and it's an amazing project
and it's just, you know,
explodes the idea of,
well, it explodes,
it really renders very clear how
diverse the medium is and how,
you know, you think of
these categories of prints,
an albumin print, platinum printing
and yes that's really a good basis
for understanding the medium
but you don't know anything
until you've seen this amazing,
you know, real-time invention
of these different
processes, anyway.
So this caught my eye and, you know,
what textured thin textured
surface combination do you prefer
and so it's, you know, I kind
of did make some other stuff up,
but a lot of it really comes right
straight out of the vocabulary,
the language of the medium
and I love this, you know.
At different times with different
jobs your preference may run
to this base, that
base, this texture,
that texture, that
gloss, this gloss.
Shuffle and reshuffle
these characteristics
into every desirable
combination [inaudible] you know,
first okay blah blah, you know,
okay and then it's really
great, you know, range.
So, you know, these things
worked in combination
for very specific purposes
and intentions
that photographers were trying to
convey and the manufacturers knew it
and the photographer's knew it.
Just back to this project
at MOMA for a second.
How can we, you know, the idea here
is to characterize papers, yes,
but to what end and I'm always
trying to think of, well, you know,
what is sort of utilitarian
end of this kind of this work.
And so this was one proof of
concept that we were working on.
Here are MOMA prints
on the left column.
So these are MOMA prints
and they're both to scale.
On the right is our prints at the
Museum of fine arts in Houston.
And what we're doing is,
what I was doing is comparing
across these collections the
materials of the photographer
across these two different
collections
and the prints were
never side-by-side.
We just went and we measured the
four expressive dimensions to see
if we could get some
information out.
And so here's the Lerski again on
the left and here is its glyph,
it's thumbprint and on the right
is the MFA Lerski and we see based
on the measurements that, you know,
it's very similar in terms of gloss
for sure and it's similar
in terms of base color
but it's got a much smoother texture
and is actually really
a thick paper.
So who knows?
We don't know if this may
be, you know, they were made
at different times
but what we do know is
that the materials are
fundamentally different
across these two identical
looking images.
Same with this, I mean it's
very different conception
from that negative, very different
composition from that negative
and fundamentally a
very different paper.
And this one is kind of the opposite
case, it's very different in terms
of its composition, its conception
but on an identical
photographic paper
so maybe these two
share a provenance.
So again if you know
the provenance of one
of these maybe you can actually
when it was made, how it was made,
why it was made, maybe
you can actually apply it
to this object as well.
So this starts to open up, you know,
some other avenues of scholarship
when it comes to understanding and
contextualizing photographic papers
or photographs not just
photographic papers,
photographs that's
what I'm talking about.
We're doing a great project now on
Moholy photograms with my friends
and colleagues at the Art Institute
- Silvi Penichau and Christel Low.
And so we're looking at about 250
photograms in different collections.
I think that's the right
number and, you know,
it's really fascinating
in terms of potential.
When you go from this to this,
these are all the different glyphs
for the collection and you
know, if you're like me,
you want to start sorting
these right away.
Let's figure out what's the same
ones, what's the different ones,
what's going on and so
that's the next, you know,
when I come back here in four years.
The last talk I gave you was
four years ago I think, you know,
I'll have some statistical methods
and some visualization tools
to actually sort this out.
In fact, I hope to have
the statistics, you know,
the ways to model this statistically
figured out really soon,
that's kind of the next step
on this work is how does
these things cluster,
and what is that tell us
about Moholy's approach
at different time periods
of his career if anything,
I think it will actually
reveal a lot.
And so the expressive
dimensions are, you know,
I'm talking about these four
expressive dimensions and I think
of course there are many more.
You can add different axes to that
glyph depending on what you need.
Here's a proposed, you know,
additional axis perhaps.
We went back, this was work that
Jennifer McGlychi [assumed spelling]
who was in my studio for a number
years did and she just went back
to the collection and a lot
of manufacturer sample books
and price lists and
encyclopedias and just pulled
out what dimensions
photographic paper was sold in
and it's a huge diversity
of dimensions, big,
small all over the place.
But if you boil it all down
it comes out I think this adds
up to what is a set up to fifty
back to Math, Andrew [inaudible].
Fifty, what is this, thirty nine
plus fifty is eighty nine, okay.
Almost ninety percent of the
things that we looked at boiled
down to these five different
aspect ratios which I think,
this is fascinating and I don't
know what this tells us about humans
and aesthetics and all of that.
But it's amazing that the
four, three ratio was used
as a whole plate daguerreotype
but also for the iPad,
I mean Steve Jobs could make the
iPad any dimensions he wanted to
but why did he do four, three
and you know, how did that work?
Maybe because he watched a lot of TV
or something I don't know, you know,
because it was LA TV as well
was the four, three dimension.
Who knows, but we can put this
information to work as well in terms
of interpreting photography or
photographs or photographers.
Here's an example, on the
left again these are to scale,
on the left is the Man Ray, Ray
graph from 1924; on the right,
a Moholy from around
the same period.
Just measure it and I measured
a bunch, I probably measured,
not sure now, maybe forty,
thirty Man Ray, Ray graphs
and about forty four percent
come out to the standard sizes,
okay, you know, whatever.
But if you look at Moholy,
about ninty percent are
these standard sizes
and so the bookmaking
photograms around the same period
but right away we can see instantly
from this very simple
metric their methodologies
and their intentions were
incredibly different.
Moholy is composing to
the sheet, you know,
photograms are really a
performance piece right,
there you placing objects,
you putting on the [inaudible]
and it's a record of
that performance.
From Moholy, the performance
is finished when it goes
into the developer and the
printers' drive, that's it.
For Man Ray, most of
the time, the final part
of the performance is he's
trimming the print and we know this
because they're nonstandard
sizes, they don't fit
into these standard sizes,
the standard aspect ratios.
And so Man Ray is trimming,
he's refining that vision,
he's making a refinement
to that performance
as his last before he it's finished.
I get some criticism, you know,
well, I don't no maybe it's just all
in my head, sometimes, I have
a lot of things that way,
you know, somewhat paranoid.
I have some trouble talking to
curators about this at times
because they think, I don't know,
maybe I'm misreading the situation
but they thinking that this is
just really a formalist exercise
where it's devoid of
context and what I'm trying
to say here is it's
all about context.
If I don't have the universe
to compare the measurements to,
then the measurements
mean very little.
It's always, the measurements
are always in comparison
to a larger body of numbers
that represent the media.
So to me it's all about context
but I think I can maybe make
that point better talking about
a project that I'm working
on at the Guggenheim right now
looking at Mapplethorpe prints
and we're specifically
looking at the prints,
the platinum palladium prints made
in the later years of his life.
This is one of those
prints made in 1988.
Mapplethorpe dies in 89, he's
diagnosed with AIDS in 86
and if you didn't know that contexts
you could perceive something is
up just by looking
at this data, okay?
And so here's that
Mapplethorpe print
and all this really is is
every print that we've looked
at going horizontally and then
the same prints going vertically
and so we're comparing each, the
texture of each print to each other
and that's what this
little chart is all about.
We don't need to know
exactly what's going
on here except what you do need
to notice or what I would like you
to notice is we've got two
really distinct clusters
and so the prints themselves
are giving you context.
The measurements made from the
prints themselves suffice something
is going on in 1986,
this breakpoint here.
And, you know, what's happening
and I've got the data to support it
and make him, I can talk
more about it, you know,
question answer but you know.
He's making actually substantially
more expressive photographs
after 1986 and so the
interpretation,
I think many interpretations
could be supported here,
but of course if you combine
that with the image and the fact
that as platinum and palladium
very permanent noble metals.
You know, he's thinking
about legacy, you know,
the formal frontal composition
but yeah but look at the paper
with this wild ductile edge.
The paper I'm sure Mapplethorpe
had no idea but the paper is
about if I get it right it's
like eighty five percent cotton
and about fifteen percent linen.
It's made by the Ashes Mill; one
of the oldest mills founded in 1492
as a matter of fact, funny
how I can remember that.
It's incredibly traditional paper;
it's got this amazing texture.
Back to the fibers for a second,
I didn't finish that point.
That fiber composition is more of
a traditional fiber composition
from it of a sheet made in the
18th, 17th century, you know,
I think it's got more of this print
has probably more in common with,
you know, a Dürer Van Stieglitz
and it goes beyond the possibilities
of silver gelatin, it's way beyond.
So he's pushing past all of that
and to me I think that's profound.
I think that's incredibly useful
information to be able to document
that and to actually be able
to effectively communicate that
and to share that which is what this
characterization agenda is really
all about.
It's giving us tools to
communicate the intrinsic value
of the materials of
the photographer.
And so that's all I have and I
would love to take some questions
and thanks for your attention.
[ Audience Clapping ]
Yeah. Please.
>> [Inaudible] terminology and
tone, paper tones [inaudible] give
that a lot and how you
describe paper tone
and how you measure paper
tone and I'm curious
about your idea [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Yeah
>> [Inaudible] influences.
>> Paul Messier: Great.
>> [Inaudible] that affect your
classification [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: So, yeah, okay,
so I am repeating the question
for because it is webcast, right?
Yeah, okay.
So let me see if I
got the summary right.
So when paper ages it yellows.
And so how does that impact
the classification scheme
and that's a really good question
and, you know, that questions
like that used to bother me
a lot because it's like "Ugh,
that wrecks everything", you
know, because we never know
like what it was originally and now
it's this but now I just feel go
with it because this was A,
there's nothing I can do about it
but be I think it's information and
I think it's fascinating to think
about photographs and
we all know this,
we all know this becoming
more expressive as they age.
I mean sometimes they don't age in
an expressive way but as, you know,
as a Stieglitz, as a Madadi gains
tone, gains some paper tone,
it becomes this more
expressive object.
And so I just don't, I just try
not to get in the way of that
and I just try to document
that but yeah I mean it's,
I could really dwell on that and
it could be a real conceptual flaw.
If you think about gloss, gloss
is also one of those dimensions
that can change fora photographic
paper specially depending
on treatment.
Treatment completely alters the
color as well but, you know,
texture we've done some
experiments in texture really seems
to hold up and is pretty robust.
And thickness really holds up too
over time, that's pretty robust
and so when it comes to this sort
of the statistical analysis of all
of these glyphs, I'm thinking
of making kind of set points
for things that don't tend to move.
So in giving them additional
weight in the statistic in any sort
of future statistical model,
does that makes sense?
Those becomes sort of the, you
know, keystones when it comes to,
that are first considered
for clustering, yeah.
Please.
>> You talk about looking at
paper in a photographic context
in comparison say [inaudible]
and other kind of print making.
Are there similar analysis or
descriptions [inaudible] out there.
>> Paul Messier: So the question is
are there similar characterization
model set up for other printmaking
media like [inaudible] prints,
lithographs and all of that.
I mean not that I know of but I mean
after today, I'm inviting everyone
up there to like go back and
think about, you know, your media
and maybe think about it in
terms of expressive dimensions.
I think that model could work,
I gave this talk or a version
of this talk at the
Reichs Museum last year
and a painting's conservator
came up to me afterwards
and said panel paintings I
think this will work great
on panel paintings.
And frankly I have no idea
how you would make that work
on panel paintings but she
did and I think that's awesome
like I said I think you could do
it for, you know, IKEA chairs,
I think you could do it
for all kinds of stuff.
So yeah, it would make a lot
of sense to start looking
at printmaking, traditional
printmaking media
and actually that's
kind of something
that is very interesting to me.
Is putting photography in a
larger context of, you know,
photography didn't
come out of the ether.
Photography is a graphic arts
medium and putting it into context
with more traditional printmaking
media is a very appealing notion.
Please, yeah.
>> I really appreciate how you've
applied this system thinking
to analysis of the characteristics
[inaudible] photographs.
I actually have come up with
the characterisation scheme
for [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Oh fantastic, okay.
>> I can [inaudible]
and [inaudible].
My question is so when you have
characterized these artists' print,
do you find in their writings
that their writings actually
corroborates your aesthetics
interpretation on the
data you have been able
to derive from your analysis?
>> Paul Messier: Okay,
so the question is,
is there documentary evidence within
an artist journals or writings that,
tell me if I'm right
here, that will correlate.
>> Yeah.
>> Paul Messier: With
the interpretation
or the characterization
scheme that I'm coming up with
and the short answer to
that is I don't know.
I've not really gone down that road
and I think that's actually a really
important, a really important thing
to do actually, you know, yeah.
It gives me some ideas
actually, yeah,
that would be a valuable thing.
Is that something that
you've been able to do
like compare what an
artist is, you know,
saying about their work
in what you're finding?
>> With regards to the
printmakers who made wood cuts,
they didn't really write
about their aesthetics.
They are a couple of sources that
talk about how to make wood cuts
but in terms of the final
characteristics and differentiation
of specific workshops and
your outputs [inaudible]
at that time [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Yeah,
is not a lot of.
>> Paul Messier: They
weren't writing.
>> About their aesthetic [inaudible]
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
>> In that way.
>> Paul Messier: Can I?
>> Unfortunately, no.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
>> But I was just wondering if there
is a line between your [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: I'm sure
there is a line, well,
lines up in some instances and
supports everything I'm doing
and I'm sure that there is like a
lot that contradict it entirely,
you know, if I started looking.
I am sure it doesn't, it's probably
not as tidy a scenario, you know.
I mean it's funny and I mean I don't
know if this goes to your point but,
you know, I'm talking about papers
here and I'm not really and I'm.
So I just want, let's see,
what am I trying to say?
Hmm, I mean you can make
an expressive photograph
on a non-expressive paper,
you know what I mean?
And so that can be part of
the artistic intent as well.
So I'm thinking like a
Bressei a [inaudible].
I saw a beautiful Bressei at
the Art Institute last week.
It's, you know, you
can lose yourself
in the deep inky amazing
blacks of a Bressei,
and he's photographing
Paris at night primarily
and he's using a very non-expressive
paper in a very expressive way
and it's highly ferrotyped.
The optical saturation of those
blacks is amazing, they're thin,
you know, it's and it's almost,
it kind of reveals the conceit
of a surrealist or a dotteist
or a surrealist primarily photograph
is the conceit is they're using
up a non-expressive paper
to convey information.
But it's of a skewed reality
and if they used expressive
paper would be too interpretive
and it would be useless
but what's communicated
by the paper is this is information,
subliminal, you know, this is what,
this is information, this is real
world and it's the dream work.
So, you know, I think a lot
about that those kinds of things
and I probably should start
integrating more to round that out,
starting integrating more about
what photographers are thinking
and saying and talking
about their work.
>> I think it would be again a
fascinating branch of your study
but your work is just absolute
[inaudible] classifications
for all kinds of graphic work and
analyzing all kinds of graphic work.
>> Paul Messier: Great
and not just IKEA chairs.
Yeah.
>> Andrew Robb: Just want to come
in to follow up on [inaudible] Okay.
>> Andrew Robb: This is to say,
I think photographers are often
describing papers that they like,
or they're sad, if they don't
have that paper anymore, you know,
often in their writing but.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah, yeah.
>> Andrew Robb: Oh I really like the
paper but they can't get in anymore
and what you're doing in a way is
figuring out a way to objectify
that description so
when they say that.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah
>> Andrew Robb: that what they need
>> Paul Messier: Yeah, yeah.
>> Andrew Robb: and they
say that this is the model
to say well there sad about this
kind of paper which is very hard
to know exactly what they're talking
about, you kind of know little bit
but this is a way to make that put
it in context to say what do you,
like why are they sad
like you, they like that.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
>> Andrew Robb: So that.
>> Andrew Robb: The time
back, that's the way
that often they are viewing
that doing that in many cases,
it's an aside, it's
not, you know, a tome.
But this is the way to unravel
what they're getting at.
And I think that would be, you'll
find examples of that, you know,
in a way [inaudible] doctors
had in articles they write
but it might be in a
more shorthand way.
It might not be in the using
that terminology that will exist.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah, so please,
we will go left to right, okay?
Well, my left.
>> This is a followup
to Andrew's question
so about your paper library.
Have you been, you know,
collecting, I know that a lot
of papers recently have just
did start up in the last,
you know, five to ten years.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> [Inaudible] papers are no longer
available so have you been kind
of collecting samples of this
at your library so that you have
that as, you know, a dictionary
for [inaudible]the
lack of a better word.
>> Catalog or pictures [inaudible]
artists you know, practicing now
or within the last twenty years, in
fifty years when we go back and look
at their work so that we have
a standard to compare them.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah, so
the question to summarize is
in my collecting contemporary
black and white materials
within the context of
the gradual disappearance
of the medium, I guess instead of.
>> Yeah.
>> Paul Messier: Fair
summary something like that.
You know and the answer is yes but
I'm, you know, it's really, yeah,
I mean the answer is yes but as I'm
not getting everything and it's kind
of frustrating, and one of the
projects that I would really
like to do is to to figure
out a way to make the catalog
and the collection much more
accessible in hopes of bringing out,
surfacing other collections.
And maybe giving sending the
message out that hey, you know,
there's a crazy guy up at
Yale who will take this stuff,
don't throw it away, you
know, when you're going.
So, yeah, I mean it's
kind of frustrating
because it is just slipping through
our fingers but I mean, you know,
the fundamental purpose
of the collection always
was, yes, to make a data set.
I have never had like sort of
antiquarian sort of interests,
but then it started to
grow on me and so then.
So now it's, you know, I
really do feel like maybe
in the end my biggest contribution
is not any of this stuff.
It's just buying a lot of
stuff on eBay and cataloging it
and sticking it in cold storage
at a major research
university, you know, yeah.
>> It's kind of seems like a natural
match with, you know, archivist
and librarians to kind of maybe
reach out to some of them and say,
hey, you know, you work with
the department, and you know,
your school or your university or
you work with yjos group of artists
as you see them transition
more and more deep, you know.
Do you have this and to figure out
someway in collaborating on that.
I don't know what it will be your,
how that will work but it seems
like that will be your [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
And so it's just to
summarize that comment.
I think that's an important
one is, well,
I don't know I'm not
summarizing you comment.
I'm making a comment to your
comment, which is, you know,
absolutely building a
network to collaborate
and share this kind of information.
I may think about it, you know,
that's kind of one of my visions
and one of my ambitions
for the Lens Media Lab is
to make not just these
glyphs available
or these statistical methods.
To make really an interface,
you know, to put it all online
and to link different
collections together.
And so when you do, when you have
a print that you want to know more
about that you can at least make a
query about what other materials are
out there like this
across different artists
within different time periods.
Imagine what amazing
and fairly simple tool
to enhance existing scholarship that
would be and what's great about that
for me as a conservator is it
really pushes forward the relevance
of materials.
You know, which sometimes get
lost in the mix when it comes
to interpreting photographs.
Sorry, yeah.
>> To follow, I'm amplifying
what Andres is bring up as well,
I was reading about just recently is
about the Art of the book in Europe
in 1939 [inaudible] 49, published
in 1951 but the sentiment
in it is still very real
about the politics of choice
and reviewing what was
able to done in the face
of incredible destruction
available in terms of machines
and [inaudible] destroy it.
So I think for, you know, another
useful layer, it's just my comments
and not really a question
but another useful layer is the
transition of the person, the maker
and where they were in time
what they could do, you know,
what they [inaudible],
what they are sending.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
>> Materials to some where
they can be retrieve it.
I am always impressed you
always state negatively.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Because we have to take that out.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
Yeah, fantastic.
Yeah, I mean it is, oh sorry Mary.
Oh I can go, I can talk more.
>> Did you want to
keep some of the point?
>> Paul Messier: I can.
So context, I think was
the underlying point there
and understanding context,
historical context in this instance.
And we're talking about, you
know, the incredible destruction
about to be unleashed
on Europe in the 30s
and how that influenced choice.
And, you know, you see that very
clearly if you look at Man Ray.
I think, you know, in
the teens, you know, he,
I think he was a brilliant artist
but he couldn't make a pictorialist
photograph to save his life
and he didn't want to because it
was irrelevant to him, you know.
After World War I in Dada,
you know, as a Dadaist.
You couldn't make a beautiful,
it didn't seem relevant,
that didn't seem, it
had to be manufactured,
it had to look objective,
it had to, you know,
back to my synonyms and antonyms.
It had to be real, it couldn't
be arty or interpreted,
it didn't make sense in that context
anymore after the First World War.
So, you know, it's
all in there, right?
>> There's a question.
>> Paul Messier: There
is a question.
>> Yeah.
>> Paul Messier: From online?
>> Paul Messier: Oh fantastic.
>> Have you considered how
image material affects texture
with platinum prints?
>> Paul Messier: Have I considered
whether image material impacts
texture when it comes
to platinum prints?
So image material I'm guessing would
be the platinum or the palladium,
that's the stuff that's making the
image and how that impacts texture.
I think the fair answer is, no,
I think this person has something
in mind that I don't have in mind
and I probably should
have in mind to be honest.
Because, yeah, I mean all these
things combine right, to take,
to look at something in exclusion
is probably a little artificial
on my part.
Is it a follow-up like
you missed the point.
>> No [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Right.
>> [Inaudible] there is
another question [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Yeah,
sure another, sure.
>> Could you speak a
bit more about process
for measuring each algorithm?
Are texture measurement
taken from [inaudible] given
that image could mute texture.
>> Paul Messier: Ah,
image can mute texture.
Okay so, yeah, I mean, okay.
So what I've presented is kind
of a condensed version
of what I'm often doing.
And so I do make texture
measurements from recto
and verso often when
I can get access
to the verso, often you cannot.
Again, I'm thinking
about statistics-based
classification schemes even though
it doesn't exist right
now and hopefully it will.
Hopefully, I'll be able to
build it, more information
for the statistical models to chew
on is probably is better right now.
But, you know, what I'm
really thinking about mostly
and what I'm really focused on
mostly is artistic intention
and I'm really thinking about
characteristics that artists
and we all in this room
can see and perceive.
So, you know, or having more
information is always better,
I'm really focused on
perceptual qualities
if that makes any sense at all.
Okay, well I have just broken the
Internet and so any other questions?
Okay.
>> I think going back
to what you were talking
about perceptual qualities,
I was thinking
about all these [inaudible]
very useful especially
when you're looking at online.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> You can actually either see these
kinds of textural characteristics.
>> Paul Messier: Absolutely.
>> You know, now, [inaudible]
a lot of research that way
but you can't immedoiately have
access to the original [inaudible].
>> Paul Messier: Absolutely.
>> It's extremely invaluable.
>> Paul Messier: Yeah, I hope
Google is listening because yeah,
I mean that's actually I mean so
the question the comment was how
if you're doing online
access, online research,
you're doing research online
you're presented with an image
but you have almost no
information about the material
and how these little
glyphs if it became kind
of a convention would
really help tremendously
and very simply communicate some
essential physical properties.
Yeah, absolutely and that's a
big part of the agenda is to kind
of get maybe try to, you know,
develop this so it becomes
really conventional.
And so when you're
cataloging a collection
and by the way the other
part when it comes to like,
are you doing the back,
are you doing the front,
are you doing image, are
you doing all of that?
Yes, and I understand in many
instances why that's valuable
but to be honest really I'm all
about high levels of throughput.
I want a lot of data; I
want a lot of photographs
to be characterized at this level.
So if before, you know, to
get that kind of buy-in,
you can't say we'll do the
XRF of the highlights that,
that's really important to
do on a case-by-case basis.
But I think these statistical
modeling in these glyphs and all
of that, what that can
do is help surface issues
that may be do merit this really
tightly focused narrow throw the
kitchen sink at it research agenda
like, wait, this is an anomaly.
We need to figure out what's
going on here and so that's
when you do the XRF in the
[inaudible] and the fiber analysis
and all of that, or here's a big
band of things that are of the same
and we know nothing about it.
So let's take us a few samples
from within that band of sameness
so we understand what's going
on, what's going on there.
So it's a little bit of the kind
of this data-driven approach
to understand where analysis
might be better focused.
Sorry I was adrift a big drift from
your initial comment, sorry, Okay,
I think I have officially used
up all the oxygen in the room
and it's getting to
dangerous levels now.
Again, thanks very, very much.
[ Audience Clapping ]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov